Cyberchondria is a real
thing, but do yourself a favor
and maybe don't Google it.
Hey, guys, this is
Annie from D News.
All of us have done it-- you're
feeling under the weather
and turn to good
old doctor internet
to figure out what ails you.
Say you have an itch in
your throat, slight fatigue.
And now that I think about it,
my foot kind of hurts, too.
And before you know
it, oh, god, I knew it.
I have fibromyalgia.
No, it's probably cancer.
It's all over.
Searching for symptoms online
is extremely common, so
common that Google
actually said this year
they can generate accurate
stats on flu outbreaks in the US
based on just search queries.
But that sense of
anxiety you get
from trying to diagnose your
mystery illness on Google, Web
M.D. or god forbid,
Yahoo Answers,
there's a name for that--
cyberchondria, a term that's
actually been
around for a while.
Back in 2001, the BBC also
called the internet printout
syndrome.
And the term has been used
in scientific journals
as far back as 2003.
But according to a new study in
the journal Cyber Psychology,
cyberchondria can have
tangible negative effects.
According to the authors
at Baylor University,
cyberchondria is a
vicious cycle that
gets worse the longer you
spend seeking out answers.
It could snowball
into additional fears
about doctor visits,
medical costs, job loss,
that rabbit-hole of stress that
can arise from health concerns.
And people who are
prone to anxiety
can be highly susceptible
to this vicious cycle.
Using anxiety measures,
the researchers
found that, kind of
unsurprisingly, people
who don't tolerate
uncertainty well or worry
a lot about the future
are the most likely to
spiral into cyberchondria,
all of which
is compounded by the
fact that there's
a ton of misinformation online.
In another study published
in the Journal of Pediatrics,
researchers looked at search
terms surrounding sudden infant
death syndrome, finding that
of 1,300 websites analyzed,
only 43.5% contained
information in line
with the recommendations
from the American Academy
of Pediatrics.
So when in doubt, seek
out a real doctor,
and be wary of the
cyberchondira cycle.
Just don't worry
about it too much.
Hey, I see you've Googling.
Stop that.
It's not helping.
Step away from
the search engine.
So do you find yourself freaking
out over medical symptoms
online?
Tell us your story
in the comments
or on Twitter and
Facebook at D News.